[Music]
come everybody gather round going to
tell you a wonderful magical tale a tale
of two Google employees who set off on a
bold journey to create a entirely
serverless application on Google cloud
some of these events might frighten you
but you're gonna learn a lot about
Google cloud and maybe even a little bit
about yourself so first the dream so if
you've if you've been around this area
you'll see a lot of these experiments
what you may not know is these
experiments are also available online
and you can go to showcase start with
Google calm and you can launch these
apps and mess with them in your own
browser you can also browse the code and
download it and launch it yourself my
friend Sundeep who you may see him
around he's also a cloud Googler him and
I had an idea to make this app a montage
maker and what a montage maker is is
it's something that will create a video
that's assembled from clips of words
from another video that have been
reordered to say or show something
different so for instance if you
uploaded a political speech then you
could make potentially by rearranging
the words set in that video you could
make the politician sing the pokemon
theme song for example so let's see what
this looks like we decided to take a
couple of videos from dev rollers from
cloud next 2018 and have them sing never
Rick Astley giving you
going to let you know okay can do that
one more time never going to give it you
up never going to let you know so not
exactly a deep fake but you get the idea
so what this consists of is a back-end
which will take a video and it will
separate it into individual word clips
for each word and a front-end that will
take a text input and it will assemble
that text into videos using the clips
that we split from the back end and what
makes this serverless well nothing makes
this server list except how we decided
to architect it so we wanted to keep
scalability in mind at the forefront so
that it can scale up automatically and
it scales down to zero and we're not
using it we also wanted it to be event
based so nothing is running until it's
fun up by something and we wanted to
have our code broken apart into micro
services and also have minimal data at
rest so
let's go to a demo hi Google cloud next
I really hope this demo works
I really hope this demo works okay good
enough thank you alright so let's talk
about how we built it the front is
pretty straightforward not really all
that much serverless going on here
anyway we have a front end being served
by firebase hosting which is a really
easy way to deploy a simple HTML app and
in JavaScript we call a back end
basically functioning as an API which is
a cloud function listening on an HTTP
HTTP trigger and that cloud function
takes a text string and looks and sees
if those clips exist in cloud storage
and if they do it combines them and if
it doesn't it fills in the missing words
with the text-to-speech API which is
what you saw with the cloud platform
logo in the previous demo so a back-end
that isn't service might look something
like this and this is your code sitting
on say compute engine a VM whatever you
give it a video it uses video
intelligence API which can give you the
start and end times for every word and
using that information cut up the video
into word clips but since we want to go
serverless for starters we decided that
we use a cloud storage bucket to
initialize the cloud function so when
you drop a video into a bucket and it
spins up our cloud function but we can
do one better because the video API
video intelligence API can save the
results of the sort and time of every
word into a JSON file in cloud storage
so now we can make that asynchronous
we're not waiting on our video
intelligence API to process our video
anymore we just sent off the API request
that function dies and then once the
video intelligence API is finished
processing a new cloud function is
triggered which then splits the word
into clips so now we have three storage
buckets on the backend one storage
bucket on the front end and at this
point if you're going I thought this was
supposed to be a happy ending story
you're not alone so this is pretty
complicated if anyone told you that
cloud functions is something that you
just run your code and you walk away you
don't have to worry about servers or
anything else any more than they lied
but before we get too discouraged let me
show you what it looks like cuz
everybody loves a good demo so here are
our cloud storage buckets I have a video
here from my good my name is Felipe
Hoffa you're interested in visualizing
Dave pre-party my good friend Felipe
Hoffa who is also a Googler
so if we architected this correctly this
will have fired off a cloud function we
can verify that this by going into our
log viewer here and it'll take a couple
of seconds but if everything goes well
there we go this is the logs for our
functions and if you're unfamiliar with
cloud functions you can break down all
of their logs right here in stackdriver
to see what they're doing at any given
time so what should have happened is
this fired off an API request to the
video intelligence API and I am
intentionally stalling because I'm
hoping when I go into montage
annotations yep sweet JSON is already
there so this is a transcription data
for our video and you can see has the
correct mostly correct sentence here
starting in x and I'm stalling again
because I'm hoping by the time I go into
here yep we have all of our videos
interesting okay awesome
so just to recap we use cloud function
functions for all the glue code we use
cloud storage for storing our data and
also for triggering additional functions
we use the video intelligence API for
identifying words in the video we use
the text-to-speech API for filling and
missing words and pub/sub maybe other
technologies used just for fun we use
firebase hosting for serving HTML nodejs
for the function code ffmpeg for any
audio or video manipulation nerds out
there we used firebase CLI to actually
deploy the functions which is it's a
really nice interface it's a really good
great way to get started we used cloud
source repositories for version control
and cloud shell editor in cloud shell
for editing the code running the test
and deploying so we were fully
integrated into the cloud with this one
let's talk about the bugs then the bugs
came so the first issue we ran into was
the video intelligence API it's just
it's really not that precise so the
precision is 1/10 of a second which if
you're talking as quickly as I am now or
as most people speak in conversation
that's not enough to really get an
isolated word so to get around that we
did a couple of things we added a second
buffer and use the fade in and fade out
which did help but at the end of the day
we just had to approve each word which
is a horrible horrible process but it's
still better than going through and
clipping these words out yourself and we
did this with an admin UI I'll show this
real quickly it's just for fun probably
one in every five words is good that's
how kubernetes unprecedented
a laptop the launch so the longer words
are better shorter words like the end
this and the real common ones are really
difficult together
now these are the more fun issues so we
started by uploading these five-minute
videos and it got chopped up about as
quickly as you saw the the demo here and
we thought this is great we aren't we
are at least we architected this thing
to scale we're feeling really good about
ourselves then we tried a 60-minute
video and can anybody guess what went
wrong
I saw the architectural diagram and we
didn't we didn't guess either but it's
actually seems really really obvious so
the first thing that happen is we hit
maximum execution time cloud function
can only run for nine minutes and we're
having it chop up sixty minutes worth of
words so you remember we have a cloud
function fire off once the annotations
land in cloud storage how do we fix it I
foreshadowed it pub/sub yes pumps up
pub/sub is a hero we need it pub/sub is
built for scalability it's highly
available its global it's awesome so we
stuck it right here we had every single
function every single word spin up a
pub/sub message to be handled by another
function we added a an additional cloud
function specifically just to clip the
words up so you're seeing micro services
in play right we're just we're cutting
this application up into the tiniest of
pieces can anyone tell me what we're
wrong with this
maximum number of parallel functions so
a 60 minute video someone talking has
10,000 words maybe something around
there 6,000 words all being processed at
the same time with a function for each
of them so here we got a little greedy
we went too far down the distribution
path and as a result of having too many
functions we then had too many
outstanding pub/sub messages as well and
we were and then what happens if you
have too many outstanding pub/sub
messages they get dropped so we were
just having words that were lost this
had a pretty easy solution we just added
batching so instead of having every
single function process one word we had
every function spin-up and processed 10
words we probably could have gone as far
as a couple hundred words because we
initially only had one function and it
was processing five minutes of video so
you know this is another one of those
trade-offs where it will get done faster
the the more these cloud functions you
spin up but then you could hit some of
these these limits so we immediately hit
the CPU quota exceeded because let's say
we had 10,000 words now we're spinning
up close to a thousand functions a
second and each of them are processing
ten words which probably takes a minute
so we're hitting this this CPU quota now
we could get around this by pausing
after so many words only processing so
many at a time what we did was we just
requested that our quota got raised
because a lot of these quotas are
configurable and and that worked so that
was nice and I'm really glad we got this
error next because it meant that we got
the Grand Slam of cloud functions errors
we hit maximum execution time maximum
number of threads maximum CPU and
maximum memory so I guess we're doing
something right now a cloud function can
only be configured for two gigabytes of
memory and that is a hard limit so when
we hit
we knew we had to fix something luckily
it was a bug in our code we had to
configure ffmpeg to use streams so it
wasn't operating on an entire 60 minute
video and there was another issue that
we had here where we were storing the
the the 60 minute video in a temp file
and not cleaning it up and and that was
an issue that's an issue that I'm going
to talk about in a second so some cloud
functions operations optimizations out
there that you really do need to keep in
mind whenever you're using cloud
functions is each function spins up an
instance specific to its function so you
have a function a function b function a
is gonna spin up a function a instance
that can handle multiple function a in
vacations so in our case when we had
these these functions that were
processing a 60-minute video each of
them were pulling down a 60-minute video
file storing it in temp and in cloud
functions the file system is memory so
you're filling up your two gigabytes of
memory and we weren't cleaning it up and
that those files stuck around until the
function ran out of memory and crashed
what we did we can actually use that to
our advantage and have every function
check and see if the video was already
downloaded and now you skip having to
download that video for each function so
you can use the temp directory and the
Global's
in cloud functions as a file set as a as
a caching system another optimization is
function size so if you use firebase CLI
it's really easy because it just takes
an app a single singular app and it
deploys it to every single function and
this is really great to get started but
once your application matures you're
going to want to split each function to
its own application so that you don't
have a function deploying with another
functions dependencies so in our case
our annotate video function which all it
does is call the video intelligence API
it was loading in three hundred
megabytes of dependencies that were
being used in some of the more complex
functions that use it used ffmpeg so
keep that in mind if you use firebase
CLI this is a ization you might want
and the g-cloud you can also deploy
functions with the G cloud CLI this is
one of the advantages it has it's a
little bit harder to use but it does
give you the ability to deploy
individual code bases so de new mom
let's resolve this story our takeaway
was building scalable service apps is
and it's not it wasn't terrible it
wasn't it wasn't great it's just a very
different paradigm and one we weren't
used to so be prepared for that did you
have different challenges you're you're
gonna run into some big frustrations I'm
gonna go through the cons first because
I want to end on a high note first one
we already talked about simple apps
seemingly simple apps get very complex
if we weren't service this is a pretty
good solution for what we wanted on our
back-end and it might actually work just
as well and this is what we came up with
this is actually the flow and this looks
insane if if someone was like hey here's
here's our app you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to debug this and they
hand me a piece of paper look like that
I would be like you guys you messed this
up this isn't right debugging and you
know as a result debugging is really
hard so we you can you can watch the
logs for for function in vacations but
at the end of the day there's no way to
see a an event go from start to finish
easily and I know there we have we have
products like cloud trace and we might
be able to integrate that in there it
didn't have time to try that so it may
be possible in the future but currently
there's nothing out of the box that
allows you to do this so you're you're
stuck looking at logs and refreshing
storage buckets which is not it's a
little more difficult to follow and
another thing is server lists abstracts
away your code from the hardware and
that's true so you don't have to worry
about hardware limitations but instead
you have quota limitations which can be
just as frustrating
so let's talk about some good things
though the app forced us to think about
microservices and as a result you get a
lot of good things with micro-services
for instance the fact that each function
is hermetic and deploying a new one is
quick and it won't affect any of the
other running components of your app
also quota exceptions were indicators of
flaws in our design every time with the
exception of the cpu quota that we had
raised we were able to get around the
quotas by better architecture of our app
and it forces to think about things that
we hadn't previously thought about quota
increases also in general are better
than adding Hardware especially if you
haven't architected your application to
scale with new hardware you just build
it on a single compute engine instance
you can add another compute engine
instance and it's not going to help you
at all
also there was very little code required
in our apps our entire and this entire
application had under 300 lines of
JavaScript and that was when I just
looked backstage before this talk I
didn't remove whitespace or comments or
logging or any of that stuff so it's I
mean it's relatively small easy to
maintain another really good aspect of
this is the cost so we talked about
scaling down to zero we left we left the
app inactive for several weeks and the
total cost was 0.1 dollar a day once in
a day
best sent today ever spent on tech and
this was just the house the videos that
we had in cloud storage our most
expensive day during development this
was when we were throwing all sorts of
videos at it and we were blowing through
quotas and we had tons of inefficiencies
and and things that were costing us
extra money was still only a hundred
bucks and the total cost with the
project over two months is was about 200
bucks so if you if you were running all
of this on a compute engine instance and
you you you really feel that you made it
really beefy so that it could hold all
this it would it would be about a $50 a
month to be pretty cheap but
whenever you're not using it you're
still paying that same price so it's
gonna catch up so it wasn't worth the
trouble of serverless I don't know I
guess that's that's for you guys to
decide thank you
[Music]